Chào mừng các bạn đến với khóa học Excel
miễn phí từ cơ bản đến nâng cao dành cho
người mới bắt đầu được thực hiện trên
kênh YouTube Gái Excel bài số 18 vẽ biểu
đồ trong Excel
trước khi bắt đầu vào bài học số 18 mình
cùng giải bài tập số 17 của hôm trước
nhá các bạn mở câu hỏi của bài số 17 lên
câu hỏi số 17 mình sẽ khóa toàn bộ các
cái ô mà chứa công thức đúng không ạ thì
đầu tiên mình phải bỏ unlock của toàn bộ
cái sheet dữ liệu này nhá các bạn sẽ lên
góc trên cùng ở bên trái này đấy các bạn
sẽ tích vào đây để các bạn lựa chọn toàn
bộ cái sheet này nhá sau đó các bạn nháy
chuột phải các bạn chọn format cell
đấy các bạn sẽ vào cái thẻ protection
này
các bạn bỏ chọn lock đi
đấy các bạn sẽ bấm ok
tiếp theo mình sẽ lựa chọn toàn bộ các
cái ô mà chứa công thức đúng không ạ thì
đầu tiên các bạn sẽ tích vào góc trên
bên trái này để các bạn lựa chọn toàn bộ
cái sheet này nhá
sau đó các bạn bấm Ctrl G để các bạn sẽ
vào cái cửa sổ go to này
các bạn sẽ chọn special
đấy và các bạn sẽ chọn cái gì ạ các bạn
sẽ chọn cái formula này
các bạn sẽ bấm ok
thì như vậy toàn bộ các ô mà chứa công
thức nó đã được lựa chọn rồi đúng không
ạ đây
đây này các cái ô mà đã được tô đậm này
là những ô chứa công thức này và cả ô
này nữa đấy
bây giờ các bạn sẽ nháy chuột phải vào
một ô chứa công thức bất kỳ nhá các bạn
sẽ chọn format cell
đấy các bạn vẫn vào thẻ protection
các bạn chọn lock
đấy các bạn sẽ bấm ok
đấy
bước thứ ba mình sẽ gì ạ mình sẽ khóa
cái sheet này nhá các bạn sẽ vào cái thẻ
review các bạn sẽ chọn cái protect sheet
này
đấy và các bạn sẽ nhập password nhá ví
dụ các bạn nhập password là gì ạ 4 5 6
đấy các bạn sẽ bấm ok
đây nó bắt mình xác nhận lại đúng không
ạ các bạn nhập 4 5 6 các bạn bấm ok đấy
thì như vậy là gì ạ toàn bộ các ô mà
chứa công thức đã được bảo vệ này bây
giờ ví dụ mình tích vào đây đấy nó sẽ
không cho mình nhập dữ liệu này. Mình
tích vào đây, nó sẽ không cho mình nhập
dữ liệu. Còn các bạn tích vào cái ô khác
thì lại ok. Đấy, các bạn có thể sửa được
ở những cái ô này.
Đấy, các bạn bấm Esc. Thì chỉ có những
cái ô chứa công thức ấy thì nó mới không
cho các bạn sửa thôi, đúng không ạ? Đấy.
Bây giờ mình muốn ẩn các ô mà chứa công
thức thì mình làm như thế nào? Tức là gì
ạ? Khi các bạn tích vào đây này, nó vẫn
hiện công thức này.
Bây giờ mình muốn là gì ạ? Khi mình tích
vào đây ấy thì nó không hiện cả cái công
thức này, thì mình làm như thế nào, đúng
không ạ?
Thì đầu tiên mình phải bỏ cái Protect
Sheet trước nhá. Vẫn là thẻ Preview này.
Các bạn chọn gì ạ? Unprotect Sheet.
Đấy, các bạn sẽ nhập password vào.
Ví dụ lúc nãy mình nhập là gì ạ? 4 5 6.
Các bạn sẽ bấm ok. Đấy. Bây giờ mình sẽ
làm lại nhá. Các bạn sẽ lựa chọn lại các
cái
cell mà gì ạ? Mà chứa công thức, đúng
không ạ? Các bạn sẽ vào đây này. Các bạn
bấm Ctrl G.
Đấy, các bạn sẽ chọn gì ạ? Các bạn chọn
Special.
Và các bạn chọn Formula. Các bạn sẽ bấm
ok.
Thì như vậy là gì ạ? Toàn bộ cái ô chứa
công thức đã được lựa chọn này. Các bạn
nháy chuột phải. Các bạn chọn Format
Cells. Đấy, hoặc phím tắt là gì ạ? Các
bạn có thể bấm phím tắt là Ctrl 1.
Đấy. Thì trong cái phần Protection này
này thì các bạn sẽ tích thêm vào cái
Hidden ở đây. Đấy. Sau đó các bạn sẽ bấm
ok.
Đấy, bước tiếp theo là các bạn sẽ gì ạ?
Các bạn sẽ vào cái Protect Sheet này.
Các bạn sẽ nhập password để bảo vệ nhá.
Ví dụ mình đánh là gì ạ? 1 2 3.
Các bạn bấm ok.
Ở đây xác nhận lại gì ạ? 1 2 3. Các bạn
sẽ bấm ok. Đấy.
Thì như vậy các cái ô này các bạn thấy
chưa? Ngoài cái việc là gì ạ? Nó không
cho các bạn chỉnh sửa ấy thì các bạn lên
cái thanh Formula Bar này, các bạn sẽ
không nhìn thấy công thức nữa. Các bạn
thấy không ạ? Đấy, rất là hay ạ.
Còn những cái ô này ấy thì nó sẽ vẫn
hiện
số liệu thông thường. Còn những cái ô mà
chứa công thức mình khóa lúc nãy ấy thì
nó sẽ không hiện công thức lên đây. Đấy,
rất là hay luôn.
Ok, như vậy là mình đã kết thúc cái câu
hỏi của bài số 17 hôm trước nhá. Mình sẽ
đóng lại này.
Bây giờ mình sẽ vào cái bài số 18 hôm
nay là vẽ biểu đồ trong Excel. Các bạn
sẽ mở cái file mẫu của bài số 18 lên.
Các bạn chú ý, mình sẽ để cái link tải
file thực hành trong phần mô tả phía
dưới video. Thì tốt nhất ấy là các bạn
tải về, các bạn vừa theo dõi và thực
hành cùng mình nhá.
Nếu bạn nào không biết cách tải về ấy
thì các bạn có thể theo dõi cái bài đầu
tiên.
Trong bài đấy mình đã hướng dẫn các bạn
là cách chi tiết để các bạn có thể tải
về.
Thì trong bài học ngày hôm nay mình sẽ
hướng dẫn các bạn cách vẽ biểu đồ trong
Excel rất là đơn giản và nhanh chóng
nhá. Thì mình sẽ làm cho các bạn ba cái
ví dụ mẫu. Đấy. Thì cái biểu đồ là gì?
Biểu đồ là cái mà các bạn muốn biểu diễn
các cái giá trị
hay là các con số dưới dạng biểu đồ.
Đấy. Thì cái biểu đồ là một cái rất là
quan trọng. Nhưng mà hầu như các bạn
không quan tâm đến biểu đồ lắm nhá.
Mà các bạn lại hay quan tâm đến các việc
sử dụng hàm hoặc là các cái công thức.
Nhưng mà ấy, khi mà các bạn ra quyết
định ấy hoặc là các sếp ấy thì người ta
hay quan tâm nhất là biểu đồ.
Bởi vì người ta sẽ dựa vào cái biểu đồ
để người ta hiểu được cái con số đấy nó
có ý nghĩa như thế nào. Và là đơn giản
hơn để họ ra được cái quyết định. Hoặc
là người ta có thể nắm được cái xu thế.
Và người ta sẽ dự báo được là tương lai
nó sẽ như thế nào.
Đấy là cái hay của biểu đồ nhá.
Thì hôm nay mình sẽ hướng dẫn các bạn
các cái cách để vẽ biểu đồ một cách đơn
giản và nhanh chóng.
Thì ở ví dụ một, giả sử ở đây mình có là
danh sách là tên các cái gì ạ? Các cái
nhân viên.
Và đây là doanh thu. Đấy, bây giờ mình
cần vẽ biểu đồ thì mình làm như thế nào?
Thì cái cách thông thường mà mọi người
hay vẽ biểu đồ nhất ấy là gì ạ? Các bạn
sẽ bôi đen cái vùng dữ liệu này.
Đấy. Sau đó các bạn vào thẻ Insert.
Đấy, các bạn sẽ nhìn sang ở đây, các bạn
sẽ thấy này. Đây là các cái loại biểu
đồ.
Thì thông thường người ta hay chọn là gì
ạ? Đây là cái biểu đồ hình cột này. Đây
là biểu đồ hình line là đường thẳng này.
Đây là biểu đồ hình gì ạ? Hình pie tức
là các cái hình tròn. Đấy. Còn các cái
biểu đồ này ấy thì
ít được sử dụng hơn nhá. Đấy. Thì trong
bài học ngày hôm nay mình sẽ hướng dẫn
các bạn là các cái biểu đồ mà thông dụng
thôi.
Còn nếu như mà các bạn không biết dùng
biểu đồ gì, thì các bạn sẽ chọn vào cái
mục recommend, đấy. Thì cái này là gì ạ?
Tức là nó sẽ dựa vào cái dữ liệu của các
bạn nhá, thì họ sẽ đề xuất vào đây. Ví
dụ mình tích vào đây đi, đấy.
Thì khi các bạn tích vào đây ý, thì nó
cũng hiện một cái danh sách là gì ạ?
Những cái biểu đồ thông dụng nhất mà cho
cái dữ liệu kiểu như thế này.
Đây là biểu đồ hình cột này. Đây là gì
ạ? Hình line này. Đây là hình pie này,
đấy.
Hoặc là gì ạ? Đây là hình cột nhưng mà
nó sẽ nằm ngang, đấy.
Hoặc là gì ạ? Các bạn sẽ vào cái thẻ all
chart, đấy.
Ở đây nó sẽ liệt kê cho các bạn tất cả
các cái kiểu đồ thị nhá, đấy.
Nó cũng giống như vậy thôi.
Đấy.
Các bạn có thể tích chọn vào đây để các
bạn xem là cái đồ thị nào mà nó phù hợp
với các bạn nhá, đấy.
Thì ví dụ mình tích vào cái hình cột này
đi, đấy, cái đầu tiên của hình cột này
nhá. Hoặc các bạn vào cái phần recommend
đây này, đấy. Mình thấy cái phần
recommend cũng khá là hay rồi. Thông
thường người ta sẽ chọn cái mục
recommend. Các bạn có thể tích vào bất
kỳ cái kiểu đồ thị nào mà các bạn mong
muốn nhá. Ví dụ mình tích vào đồ thị
hình cột nhưng mà nó sẽ nằm ngang này.
Các bạn sẽ bấm ok. Đấy, thì như vậy là
mình đã được cái đồ thị
biểu diễn gì ạ? Doanh thu của các bạn
nhân viên từ cái Excel 1 đến cái Excel
5, các bạn thấy không? Đấy.
Rất là hay ạ.
Mình sẽ giới thiệu một số cái thành phần
nhá. Thì đầu tiên cái doanh thu ở đây ý
là cái tiêu đề, đấy. Các bạn có thể sửa
cái tiêu đề này bằng cách gì ạ? Các bạn
tích vào đây. Sau đó các bạn bôi đen vào
các bạn sửa nhá. Đây ví dụ mình có thể
ghi là gì ạ? Doanh thu.
Doanh thu nhân viên chẳng hạn thế nhá,
đấy, tùy các bạn. Các bạn có thể sửa
nhá.
Hoặc là gì ạ? Các bạn có thể để công
thức cho cái phần tiêu đề. Các bạn sẽ
tích vào cái phần tiêu đề này này, sau
đó các bạn lên cái thanh formula 3, các
bạn sẽ gán bằng.
Và các bạn có thể gán đến một cái ô nào
đấy. Ví dụ mình tích vào cái ô này đi,
là cái ô C5, đấy, các bạn enter.
Thì như vậy là gì ạ?
Cái tiêu đề của cái đồ thị này nó sẽ lấy
ở cái ô C5 này. Bây giờ ví dụ mình ghi ở
đây là gì ạ?
Đây là lợi nhuận chẳng hạn thế nhá. Ví
dụ thôi.
Các bạn enter.
Thì như vậy cái tiêu đề nó sẽ đổi thành
cái gì ạ? Lợi nhuận. Đấy, ví dụ mình
undo đi.
Tiếp theo là đây là cái trục dữ liệu của
mình nhá.
Thì đây là tên của các cái nhân viên.
Đấy, nó lại làm ngược lại, tức là từ cái
bạn cuối cùng đến cái bạn trên này. Bây
giờ mình muốn đổi cái thứ tự này thì
mình làm như thế nào?
Thì các bạn có thể tích đúp vào cái phần
tên của các cái nhân viên này này.
Đấy. Các bạn có thể đóng lại. Hoặc là gì
ạ? Các bạn sẽ tích vào tên các nhân viên
và các bạn ấn phím tắt là Ctrl 1. Đấy,
đấy là cái cách để mình hiện cái cửa sổ
format của cái vùng gì ạ? Vùng tên ở
đây.
Sau đó các bạn sẽ tích vào đây là cái gì
ạ? Axis Option đây này. Các bạn lăn
xuống dưới nhá.
Đấy.
Các bạn sẽ chọn cái phần gì ạ? Category
in reverse order. Đấy, các bạn tích vào
đây. Đấy, các bạn thấy chưa? Thì lúc này
nó sẽ sắp xếp ngược lại từ gái sale 1
đến gì ạ? Đến gái sale 5. Đấy, các bạn
thấy không? Rất là hay ạ.
Đấy, mình có thể đóng cái này lại.
Tiếp theo là gì ạ? Đây là các cái
giá trị doanh thu của các bạn đây, đúng
không ạ? Nếu như các bạn tích vào một ô
như lúc nãy ạ, các bạn tích vào đây ý
thì nó sẽ lựa chọn toàn bộ gì ạ? Toàn bộ
doanh thu của các bạn. Nếu các bạn tích
thêm một lần nữa ấy thì nó sẽ lựa chọn
cái doanh thu của một cái bạn cụ thể ở
đây. Đấy. Bây giờ ví dụ mình muốn tích
cái doanh thu của bạn gái sale 3 nhá.
Bây giờ mình sẽ sẽ thoát ra ngoài này.
Nếu như các bạn muốn lựa chọn doanh thu
của bạn gái sale 3, các bạn sẽ tích vào
đây.
Thì khi các bạn tích một lần ý thì nó sẽ
lựa chọn toàn bộ doanh thu của các cái
nhân viên ở đây. Các bạn phải tích thêm
một lần nữa thì nó mới lựa chọn doanh
thu của cái bạn gái sale 3 này. Đấy, đấy
là cái cách mà mình sẽ lựa chọn. Nếu như
các bạn muốn hiện cái giá trị của bạn
gái sale 3 nhá, các bạn có thể nháy
chuột phải này. Các bạn sẽ chọn là Add
Data Label ở đây.
Và các bạn chọn gì ạ? Add Data Label.
Đấy, thì như vậy là gì ạ? Nó sẽ hiện cái
giá trị của cái bạn gái sale 3 này.
Ok, bây giờ giả sử mình muốn xóa cái gì
ạ? Mình muốn xóa cái data label của cái
bạn gái sale 3 nhá. Thì các bạn chỉ cần
tích vào đây này. Đấy, nó sẽ lựa chọn
cái giá trị 24 ở đây chính là cái doanh
thu của bạn gái sale 3 nhá. Các bạn sẽ
bấm delete đi. Đấy. Bây giờ giả sử mình
muốn hiện doanh thu của toàn bộ các bạn
gái sale ở đây nhá. Thì các bạn sẽ tích
vào doanh thu của một cái bạn bất kỳ.
Đấy. Các bạn chỉ cần tích một lần thôi
thì nó sẽ lựa chọn toàn bộ doanh thu của
năm bạn gái sale ở đây. Các bạn sẽ nháy
chuột phải này. Các bạn sẽ chọn là add
data label ở đây. Các bạn sẽ trỏ vào cái
nút tam giác này. Các bạn sẽ chọn gì ạ?
Add data label. Đấy. Thì như vậy là gì
ạ? Các cái doanh thu của bạn gái sale
này nó sẽ add vào đây. Các bạn thấy
không? Rất là hay ạ.
Các bạn sẽ tích vào doanh thu của một
bạn bất kỳ nhá. Thì nó sẽ lựa chọn doanh
thu của toàn bộ các bạn. Các bạn tích
thêm một lần nữa thì nó sẽ lựa chọn một
cái doanh thu cụ thể. Đấy. Đấy là cái
các cái cách để mình sẽ lựa chọn nhá.
Bây giờ ví dụ mình tích vào doanh thu ở
đây. Sau đó các bạn nháy chuột phải này.
Các bạn sẽ chọn là format data label.
Hoặc các bạn có thể gì ạ? Ấn phím tắt là
Ctrl 1 nhá.
Ví dụ mình bấm phím tắt là Ctrl 1 đi.
Đấy.
Ở đây nhá, nó sẽ có một số cái tùy chọn
cho cái vị trí mà mình hiển thị cái giá
trị ở đây. Đây là center này. Đấy, các
bạn sẽ tích vào các bạn nhìn thấy này.
Center là
thì nó sẽ nằm ở giữa cái phần doanh thu
này.
Inside end này. Đấy. Inside base tức là
sẽ gì ạ? Góc bên trái ở đây. Đấy. Thì
thông thường người ta hay chọn là inside
base hoặc là gì ạ? Outside end. Đấy.
Các bạn có thể cho màu nhá. Ví dụ mình
sẽ chọn là gì ạ? Inside base. Đấy, mình
sẽ cho là gì ạ? Mình sẽ cho nó màu trắng
đi.
Mình sẽ tô đậm đi. Đấy.
Thì như vậy là gì ạ? Đây là các giá trị
doanh thu của các bạn ở đây.
Những cái đồ thị line này nhá là nó sẽ
biểu diễn các cái gì ạ? Các cái đơn vị
cho các bạn dễ nhìn thôi. Đấy.
Bây giờ mình sẽ tích vào đây. Và các bạn
bấm delete đi. Tức là mình sẽ xóa cái
thanh dọc này đi. Mình thấy nhìn nó sẽ
đẹp hơn đấy.
Ok. Tiếp theo là gì ạ? Các bạn sẽ nhìn
vào cái dấu cộng này này. Nó sẽ có một
số cái tùy chọn cho các bạn. Đây là gì
ạ? Các bạn sẽ add thêm cái gì ạ? Cái
tiêu đề. Nếu như các bạn tích vào đây
thì các bạn sẽ tiêu đề cho cái vùng dữ
liệu ở đây này. Đấy, thì mình có thể
đánh vào đây là gì ạ? Đấy, thì tùy các
bạn nhá. Cái này mình nghĩ là không cần
thiết thì các bạn bỏ đi. Đấy.
Đây là cái hiện data table. Khi các bạn
trỏ vào ấy thì các bạn sẽ nhìn sang cái
phần đồ thị nó sẽ có tương ứng để các
bạn chọn nhá. Nếu như mình bỏ qua thì
các bạn lại di chuột ra chỗ khác thôi.
Đấy. Đây là cái cách mà các bạn muốn
hiển thị. Đây là cái gridline lúc nãy
mình xóa đi này. Nếu như các bạn muốn
chọn lại nhá thì các bạn tích vào đây.
Đấy, thì nó lại hiện lại cái gridline ở
đây thôi ạ. Đấy. Đây là cái gì ạ? Cái
legend, tức là cái doanh thu ở đây này.
Mình cũng không cần thiết cái thì các
bạn bỏ đi. Đấy.
Đây là cái trend thôi.
Ok.
Các bạn sẽ đóng cái cửa sổ format này
lại nhá.
Bây giờ để xóa cái biểu đồ này thì các
bạn làm như thế nào? Các bạn sẽ nháy
chuột phải vào biểu đồ. Các bạn chọn cắt
đi là được. Đấy.
Cách thứ hai để mình vẽ biểu đồ nhá thì
các bạn có thể tích vào một ô bất kỳ
cũng được. Đấy, sau đó các bạn vào thẻ
insert. Và các bạn chọn một cái loại
biểu đồ thôi. Đấy, ví dụ mình chọn cái
biểu đồ hình cột này đi. Chọn cái đầu
tiên này nhá. Đấy, các bạn thấy chưa?
Thì vì là gì ạ? Cái biểu đồ này mình vẽ
ở một cái ô trống đúng không? Thì nó sẽ
không có cái dữ liệu gì cả, đúng không?
Đấy. Thì khi mà cái biểu đồ nó hiện ra
đây ấy mà các bạn tích vào cái biểu đồ
ấy thì các bạn sẽ thấy ở đây nó sẽ có
thêm hai cái thẻ là thẻ design và thẻ
format. Bây giờ các bạn sẽ tích ra
ngoài. Đấy, các bạn thấy chưa? Không còn
cái thẻ design và thẻ format nữa. Khi
các bạn tích vào cái phần biểu đồ ấy thì
các bạn mới thấy được cái thẻ design và
thẻ format nhá. Đấy. Bây giờ các bạn sẽ
vào cái thẻ design này. Các bạn sẽ chọn
là cái select data.
Hoặc các bạn sẽ nháy chuột phải và các
bạn chọn là gì ạ? Chọn select data. Đấy.
Thì một cái cửa sổ select data đã hiện
ra, đúng không?
Các bạn có thể chọn cái add ở đây.
Đấy, thì khi các bạn chọn add ở đây ấy
thì nó yêu cầu là gì ạ? Cái series name.
Thì ví dụ mình chọn là cái doanh thu đi.
Đấy. Và cái giá trị của doanh thu bây
giờ các bạn tích xuống dưới các bạn xóa
cái này đi.
Và các bạn sẽ chọn là cái vùng doanh thu
của các bạn. Đấy, các bạn sẽ bấm ok.
Thì như vậy các bạn nhìn thấy là gì ạ?
Đây cái phần đồ thị đây này.
Đây này, doanh thu đây này. Đấy. Bây giờ
mình sẽ sửa nhá. Các bạn sẽ tích vào cái
phần edit ở đây là gì ạ? Thay vì mình
hiện các cái số từ 1 đến 5 này thì mình
sẽ hiện tên của các cái nhân viên tương
ứng đúng không? Các bạn sẽ tích vào edit
ở đây.
Đấy, nó sẽ hiện một cái cửa sổ là axis
label đúng không? Các bạn sẽ tích vào
đây và các bạn sẽ bôi đen
danh sách nhân viên. Đấy, các bạn sẽ bấm
ok.
Đấy, các bạn thấy chưa? Như vậy là gì ạ?
Nó đã hiện doanh thu của các cái nhân
viên này.
Đấy, rất là hay ạ.
Các bạn sẽ bấm ok.
Đấy là cái cách nhá. Hoặc cách thứ hai
là gì ạ? Các bạn có thể nháy chuột phải
này. Các bạn chọn là select data.
Và các bạn lên cái phần chart data range
này. Nếu như các bạn xóa đi nhá.
Đấy, và các bạn có thể chọn toàn bộ cái
vùng này.
Các bạn bấm ok cũng được. Đấy là một cái
cách khác nhá. Nó sẽ nhanh hơn.
Ok, bây giờ giả sử mình muốn thêm một
cái dữ liệu khác là gì ạ? Bây giờ ví dụ
mình có một cái dữ liệu khác là kế hoạch
chẳng hạn đi nhá.
Đấy, đây là cái doanh thu mà đạt được
còn đây là cái kế hoạch. Ví dụ, bạn này
là 12 này. Bạn này là 35 này. Đấy, bạn
này là 29 này.
Thì tùy cái mục tiêu nhá. Ví dụ, bạn này
là 15. Đấy, bạn này là 20 cơ. Đấy, bây
giờ mình muốn vẽ thêm cái đồ thị của cái
phần kế hoạch thì các bạn làm như thế
nào?
Một cách rất đơn giản là cái gì ạ? Các
bạn sẽ tích vào cái phần biểu đồ ở đây.
Đấy. Khi các bạn tích vào cái phần biểu
đồ đây này
thì các bạn thấy chưa? Cái vùng dữ liệu
của mình nó được gì ạ? Được tô đậm này.
Bây giờ các bạn chỉ cần di chuột vào
đây.
Đấy, khi mà nó hiện cái gì ạ? Cái mũi
tên mà nó sẽ hơi chéo ra một tí này. Các
bạn giữ chuột trái và các bạn kéo sang
đây.
Các bạn sẽ kéo sang phải để nó sẽ lựa
chọn thêm cái phần kế hoạch đây này.
Đấy, các bạn thấy chưa? Thì như vậy nó
sẽ có hai cái dữ liệu. Cái xanh này là
doanh thu và cái vàng này là kế hoạch.
Đấy. Các bạn có thể tích vào cái dấu
cộng này nhá.
Đây này, các bạn sẽ chọn cái Legend ở
đây. Đấy, các bạn sẽ tích vào đây thì
các bạn sẽ hiểu là gì ạ?
Cái màu xanh là gì và màu vàng là gì?
Các bạn sẽ tích vào cái Legend, các bạn
tích vào cái tam giác đây này.
Các bạn muốn cái vị trí của cái Legend
này nó hiển thị, đây ví dụ mình cho là
top đi. Đấy.
Các bạn sẽ tích vào đây, các bạn có thể
kéo sang một cái góc khác cũng được.
Đấy. Nhìn nó sẽ đẹp hơn đúng không?
Thì như vậy các bạn sẽ biết được là gì
ạ? Màu xanh là doanh thu và cái màu vàng
là kế hoạch. Đấy.
Hoặc cái cách thứ hai là gì ạ? Bây giờ
ví dụ mình ấn undo đi.
Undo lại nhá.
Đấy. Bây giờ mình muốn lựa chọn thêm cái
vùng dữ liệu của cái kế hoạch nhá. Các
bạn có thể nháy chuột phải vào đây. Các
bạn chọn gì ạ? Chọn
Select data. Đấy. Và các bạn gì ạ? Các
bạn chỉ cần bấm thêm cái phím add này
này. Đấy.
Thì nó sẽ hiện một cái cửa sổ là edit
series nhá. Các bạn sẽ tích thêm vào cái
mục gì ạ? Mình muốn hiển thị cái phần kế
hoạch này.
Cái phần value các bạn xóa đi và các bạn
sẽ lựa chọn toàn bộ lại cái phần kế
hoạch ở đây. Các bạn sẽ bấm ok.
Đấy, các bạn thấy chưa?
Đây, nó sẽ cũng ra cái kết quả tương tự.
Đấy, rất là hay ạ.
Mình sẽ tích vào đây, các bạn sẽ tích
thêm cái Legend ở đây.
Các bạn sẽ tích vào cái tam giác này
nhá. Mình sẽ chọn ở top đi. Hoặc là
bottom ở dưới đi. Đấy.
Thì tùy các bạn muốn hiện cái
tên của các cái biểu đồ này. Doanh thu
là màu xanh và gì ạ? Màu cam là kế
hoạch. Đấy, các bạn có thể tích vào cái
phần kế hoạch này nhá. Các bạn có thể
đổi cái màu cho nó cũng được nhá. Đấy.
Có nhiều cách để đổi màu, ví dụ thông
thường các bạn sẽ tích vào đây và các
bạn sẽ chọn luôn cái fill là màu gì.
Đấy, thì tùy các bạn nhá. Nếu như mà các
bạn không thích cái màu này thì các bạn
sẽ đổi sang màu khác. Đấy.
Ví dụ mình cho là màu à này đi.
Đấy, đấy là cái cách để các bạn đổi màu
nhá.
Bây giờ các bạn sẽ tích vào cái đồ thị
này. Đấy, các bạn sẽ vào cái thẻ design.
Trong này nó sẽ có một số cái kiểu chart
title nhá.
Thì các bạn xem cái phần gì ạ? Các bạn
nhìn cái phần nào mà các bạn muốn. Đấy.
Nó sẽ có một số cái mẫu hoặc các bạn
tích vào đây thì nó sẽ có nhiều mẫu cho
các bạn. Và các bạn nhìn cái đồ thị nào
mà các bạn thấy hợp ấy, thì các bạn chọn
nhá. Đây ví dụ mình thấy cái này cũng
khá là hay, thì các bạn sẽ tích vào đây.
Đấy, thì tùy các bạn nhá.
Các bạn sẽ tích đúp vào cái phần đồ thị
này.
Đấy, thì nó sẽ hiện một cái cửa sổ
format chart area.
Thì các bạn chú ý nhá, mình sẽ giới
thiệu qua về cái format này. Thì đầu
tiên là cái chart option nhá, các bạn sẽ
tích vào đây.
Thì trong cái chart option này ấy, nhiều
bạn không biết đâu, là gì ạ? Các bạn có
thể lựa chọn các cái thành phần
của cái phần biểu đồ. Ví dụ mình chọn
vào cái này đi. Đấy, các bạn thấy chưa?
Thì nó là gì ạ? Nó sẽ bôi đen các cái
tên này.
Hoặc là các bạn tích vào đây, các bạn
muốn lựa chọn ví dụ cái legend ở đây,
chính là gì ạ? Chính là cái
tên này, doanh thu và kế hoạch ở đây.
Đấy, đây đây là cái cách để các bạn có
thể lựa chọn. Ví dụ mình chọn toàn bộ
cái phần doanh thu nhá. Đấy, các bạn
thấy chưa? Như vậy cái biểu đồ doanh thu
đã được lựa chọn này. Đấy, đây là cái
cách để mình sẽ lựa chọn các cái thành
phần của cái biểu đồ.
Bây giờ ví dụ mình lựa chọn là cái kế
hoạch đi. Đấy, các bạn thấy chưa? Cái kế
hoạch này.
Cái phần gap width ở đây này, các bạn có
thể
thu nhỏ lại là gì ạ? Nó sẽ co nhỏ cái độ
rộng gì ạ? Giữa hai cái khoảng trống của
các cái nhân viên ở đây. Đấy, nếu như
các bạn về nhỏ nhất là 0 ấy, thì nó sẽ
dính chặt vào nhau. Thì nó khá là xấu
đúng không? Mình sẽ để nó một khoảng
rộng nhất định. Đấy, thì tùy các bạn
nhá. Các bạn thích cái khoảng rộng giữa
hai cái vạch, thì mình sẽ co giãn cái
gap width này nhá.
Ok, bây giờ mình có thể thay đổi cái
kiểu đồ thị nhá. Đấy, thì mình đã lựa
chọn cái cột kế hoạch ở đây. Đấy, bây
giờ mình muốn biểu diễn lại cái kiểu đồ
thị của cái phần kế hoạch này nhá. Các
bạn sẽ nháy chuột phải vào một cái cột
kế hoạch bất kỳ này.
Các bạn sẽ chọn gì ạ? Các bạn sẽ chọn
cái change series chart type.
Đấy, tức là mình sẽ thay đổi cái kiểu đồ
thị của cái phần kế hoạch thôi đúng
không?
Thì nó sẽ vào cái phần combo đây, tức là
nó sẽ kết hợp đúng không? Các bạn sẽ
tích vào cái kế hoạch ở đây. Đấy.
Thì đây các bạn chú ý nhá, cái phần này
ấy, nó chỉ có từ cái Excel 2016 trở về
sau thôi, tức là 2016 hoặc 2019 thôi,
hoặc Office 365 nhá. Còn nếu như các bạn
dùng 2013 ấy thì nó sẽ không có cái này.
Thì các bạn phải dùng các cái cách khác
nhá.
Đấy, thì các bạn sẽ thay đổi này, ví dụ
mình sẽ chọn vào đây. Các bạn sẽ chọn
cái kiểu đồ thị, ví dụ mình chọn là line
đi.
Đấy. Thì các bạn thấy chưa? Như vậy là
cái gì ạ? Cái thực hiện là cái hộ đồ thị
cột, còn cái kế hoạch là cái hình line
này. Đấy, các bạn sẽ bấm ok.
Đấy. Bây giờ các bạn sẽ tích vào gì ạ?
Bây giờ mình sẽ tích vào cái line này
nhá. Đấy.
Các bạn sẽ vào cái phần gì ạ? Đây là
fill and line này.
Bây giờ là các bạn sẽ tích vào cái gì ạ?
Bây giờ mình không muốn hiện cái line
đâu nhá, các bạn sẽ tích vào cái no
line.
Và các bạn sẽ chọn cái marker, tức là
mình sẽ biểu diễn.
Đây, các bạn sẽ tích vào cái marker
option này.
Bây giờ mình sẽ gì ạ? Build in này. Đây,
bây giờ mình sẽ chọn, ví dụ mình chọn
cái gạch ngang này đi.
Mình cho cái size nó lớn lên một tí, cỡ
10 chẳng hạn thế nhá. Đây, các bạn thấy
chưa? Khá là hay rồi đúng không? Đấy.
Bây giờ mình sẽ đóng cái này lại.
Như vậy cái phần thực hiện là cái phần
cột này, còn cái doanh thu là cái gạch
ngang này. Các bạn nhìn thấy không? Rất
là đẹp. Bây giờ các bạn sẽ tích vào cái
value của cái phần kế hoạch nhá. Các bạn
chỉ cần tích vào một cái thôi thì nó sẽ
gì ạ? Lựa chọn toàn bộ ở đây. Đấy. Các
bạn sẽ nháy chuột phải này, các bạn chọn
gì ạ? Format data label. Đấy. Bây giờ
mình sẽ vào cái vị trí, ví dụ mình cho
cái above đi.
Đấy.
Bây giờ mình sẽ không để màu trắng nữa
nhá. Mình sẽ lại cho, mình sẽ cho về nó
về màu đen đi. Các bạn sẽ vào cái thẻ
home.
Mình sẽ cho nó là màu đen đi, automatic
này. Đấy. Bây giờ lại, các bạn lại tích
vào cái value của cái phần doanh thu ở
đây.
Đấy, các bạn sẽ gì ạ? Các bạn sẽ lăn
xuống này. Các bạn sẽ cho ở cái chỗ là
gì ạ?
Inside bar đi. Đấy.
Các bạn sẽ close này lại. Đấy. Các bạn
nhìn thấy không? Khá là hay ạ.
Thì như vậy là gì ạ? Doanh thu thực hiện
nó sẽ nằm ở dưới này. Đây là cái kế
hoạch.
Đấy, nhìn nó rất là đẹp rồi đúng không?
Đấy. Đây Đây là một số cái cách thông
thường để mình vẽ biểu đồ nhá.
Sang cái ví dụ thứ hai, bây giờ mình sẽ
đóng cái này lại. Các bạn nhớ chuột phải
các bạn cắt đi.
Bây giờ sang ví dụ thứ hai là gì ạ? Mình
sẽ vẽ biểu đồ là gì? Đây là theo năm
này.
Đấy, đây là theo quý và đây là kế hoạch,
đây là đã thực hiện nhá.
Thì các bạn cũng rất là đơn giản, các
bạn bôi đen toàn bộ cái vùng dữ liệu.
Đấy, các bạn vào thẻ insert. Và các bạn
chọn một số cái kiểu đồ thị mà các bạn
mong muốn nhá. Thì tốt nhất ấy là các
bạn chưa thành thạo ấy thì các bạn sẽ
tích vào cái phần recommend ở đây.
Đấy.
Thì nó sẽ có một số cái kiểu đồ thị mẫu
để các bạn chọn.
Đấy, cái nào phù hợp thì các bạn chọn
nhá. Đây, ví dụ mình chọn vào cái này
đi, mình thấy khá là đẹp này. Các bạn sẽ
bấm ok.
Đấy.
Thì đây, các bạn thấy chưa? Đây nó sẽ
chia thành các cái ngăn. Ví dụ năm 2018
là một ngăn này, 2019 là một ngăn và
đây là đây là 2020 chứ ạ? Mình sẽ sửa
lại này.
Đấy, thì 2020 là một ngăn. Đấy, các bạn
thấy không? Rất là đẹp luôn.
Bây giờ các bạn sẽ nhấp tích vào một cái
cột bất kỳ ở đây nhá, mình sẽ co cái
phần độ rộng này lại. Nhìn nó sẽ đẹp hơn
này. Đấy. Các bạn sẽ tích đúp nhá hoặc
các bạn ấn Ctrl 1 cũng được. Thì bây giờ
ví dụ mình ấn Ctrl 1 nhá. Đấy, thì nó sẽ
hiện cái cửa sổ format lên và các bạn gì
ạ?
Các bạn giảm cái này đi để nó gì ạ? Nó
cái độ rộng của cái cột này nó sẽ to ra,
tức là cái khoảng cách gì ạ? Giữa các
giá trị nó sẽ co lại. Đấy.
Mình sẽ giảm cái này đi.
Đấy, các bạn sẽ chỉnh đến một cái giá
trị mà các bạn thấy hợp lý là được. Đấy.
Các bạn thấy không? Nó khá là hay rồi ạ.
Đấy, và các bạn sẽ chỉnh. Ví dụ các bạn
có thể add thêm value hoặc các bạn sẽ
đổi cái tiêu đề. Ví dụ mình tích vào đây
mình sửa tiêu đề là gì ạ?
Đây là doanh thu
theo năm chẳng hạn thế nhá.
Đấy, ví dụ thôi ạ.
Cái phần này các bạn có thể di ra đâu
cũng được ạ. Đấy, các bạn có thể di sang
góc này. Thì tùy các bạn nhá.
Bây giờ giả sử mình có thêm một cái dữ
liệu mới nhá là cái gì ạ? Cái phần trăm
hoàn thành đi. Đấy, phần trăm hoàn
thành. Đấy, phần trăm hoàn thành sẽ bằng
gì? Bằng cái thực hiện này, các bạn chia
cho gì? Chia cho kế hoạch. Các bạn
enter.
Đấy. Các bạn tích vào đây, sau đó các
bạn tích đúp này.
Mình sẽ gì ạ? Mình sẽ vào thẻ home, mình
để dưới dạng phần trăm đi.
Bây giờ mình muốn dữ liệu của cái phần
trăm hoàn thành mình sẽ add thêm vào cái
biểu đồ này thì mình làm như thế nào?
Đấy. Thì cũng rất là đơn giản thôi. Các
bạn có thể nháy chuột phải này.
Đấy, các bạn có thể chọn select data
hoặc gì ạ? Các bạn sẽ tích vào cái biểu
đồ này. Và các bạn kéo sang đây thôi.
Đấy. Thì như vậy các bạn chú ý nhá. Vì
cái hoàn thành của mình ở đây rất là nhỏ
đúng không? So với cả cái giá trị mà kế
hoạch và đã thực hiện. Thì cái hoàn
thành nó đều là nhỏ hơn một chẳng hạn
thế nhá. Thì nó sẽ tít ở dưới này cơ.
Các bạn thấy chưa? Đấy. Bây giờ làm sao
để lựa chọn được cái gì ạ? Cái hoàn
thành ở đây rất là khó lựa chọn đúng
không?
Thì các bạn sẽ tích đúp vào cái biểu đồ
này. Và các bạn sẽ chọn cái chart option
ở đây. Và các bạn sẽ chọn cái phần trăm
hoàn thành ở đây này. Đấy. Thì như vậy
tất cả cái phần trăm hoàn thành đã được
gì ạ? Lựa chọn rồi.
Bây giờ mình sẽ biểu diễn cái phần trăm
hoàn thành dưới dạng cái cột phụ. Các
bạn hiểu không ạ? Tức là gì ạ? Mình sẽ
lựa chọn nó. Để biểu diễn ở một cái trục
khác nhá. Trục phụ đấy.
Đấy. Bây giờ mình sẽ vào lại này. Các
bạn chọn gì? Phần trăm hoàn thành. Đấy.
Các bạn sẽ tích vào đây là gì ạ? Series
option này. Đấy, các bạn thấy chưa? Mình
sẽ lựa chọn cái trục phụ ở đây. Là cái
trục thứ hai này. Và gì ạ? Các bạn thấy
chưa? Cái phần trăm hoàn thành nó đang
là màu bạc đúng không? Bây giờ mình sẽ
đổi
cái kiểu đồ thị nhá. Các bạn nháy chuột
phải này.
Các bạn chọn gì ạ?
Change series chart type.
Đấy, các bạn sẽ tích vào cái phần trăm
hoàn thành ở đây.
Mình sẽ đổi nó là cái line này đi.
Đấy. Các bạn thấy không? Lúc này nó khá
là hay ạ.
Các bạn sẽ bấm ok. Thì như vậy là gì ạ?
Cái line này là phần trăm hoàn thành là
cái trục phụ ở bên phải này. Còn hai cái
là gì ạ? Cái kế hoạch và cái đã thực
hiện nó sẽ là gì ạ? Giá trị ở cái trục
chính là trục bên trái này.
Đấy.
Mình sẽ đóng lại nhá. Đấy. Cái này cũng
khá là hay đúng không?
Các bạn có thể add value nhá. Các bạn
tích vào đây, sau đó là gì ạ? Các bạn
nháy chuột phải. Các bạn chọn add data
label. Đấy, các bạn tích vào cái phần
tam giác này.
Add data label. Đấy.
Các bạn sẽ tích vào cái
label này đấy các bạn sẽ nháy chuột phải
các bạn sẽ chọn format data label. Ví dụ
mình cho là
mình không nên để bên phải nha mình cho
là above đi.
Các bạn có thể để format nha nếu như các
bạn muốn hiện là gì ạ? Không phải là làm
tròn là 67% mà gì các bạn tích vào
number đây này. Các bạn sẽ chọn một số
format đây ví dụ cái format ở đây các
bạn sẽ ghi là gì ạ?
Thăng chấm 00 đấy xong phần trăm.
Các bạn sẽ bấm add. Đấy như vậy là gì ạ?
Nó sẽ hiện là gì ạ?
Hai cái số thập phân sau cái phần trăm
đấy. Nhưng mà nhìn cái này cũng khá là
xấu đúng không? Các bạn sẽ tích vào đây.
Đấy các bạn sẽ làm lại nha.
Các bạn sẽ chọn vào cái number. Đấy mình
sẽ đổi là gì ạ?
Mình sẽ là thăng phần trăm thôi đấy nhìn
nó sẽ đẹp hơn thôi. Tức là mình sẽ không
để cái phần thập phân nha. Đấy là mình
biểu diễn cho các bạn hiểu thôi ạ.
Ok mình sẽ đóng lại.
Đấy là cái cách để mình sẽ thêm cái trục
phụ ở đây này đấy là cái phần trăm hoàn
thành chẳng hạn thế nha. Tức là hai cái
giá trị khác nhau một cái là biểu diễn
dưới dạng số một cái là biểu diễn dưới
dạng phần trăm.
Ok sang ví dụ thứ ba là gì ạ? Đây là
mình có gì ạ? Doanh thu của các quý nha.
Ví dụ là quý một quý hai quý ba quý bốn
chẳng hạn của năm cái bạn nhân viên này.
Thì mình sẽ vẽ biểu đồ cái
kiểu khác đi đấy các bạn sẽ bôi đen cái
vùng dữ liệu này. Các bạn vào thẻ insert
này các bạn sẽ vào cái biểu đồ hình cột
đi. Đấy mình sẽ chọn cái hình cột này
đi.
Đấy màu xanh là của quý một này màu cam
là quý hai này màu xám là quý ba và màu
gì ạ? Đây là màu nghệ này là quý bốn.
Đấy các bạn thấy chưa? Bốn cái màu này
rất là đẹp và nó sẽ gì ạ? Nó sẽ chồng
lên nhau để các bạn thấy được là cái
doanh thu tổng đây các bạn thấy không?
Rất là hay ạ.
Bây giờ ví dụ mình muốn biểu diễn cái
tổng nữa nha các bạn tích vào đây các
bạn sẽ ghi là gì ạ?
Ví dụ mình ghi là total chẳng hạn thế
nha. Các bạn sẽ bằng này.
Các bạn sẽ tích vào cái tên này nha. Đấy
sau đó các bạn và với gì? Đây mình sẽ
giải thích cho các bạn sau nha các bạn
sẽ mở ngoặc kép ra. Các bạn sẽ thêm cái
dấu gì ạ? Mở ngoặc đơn này các bạn đóng
ngoặc kép lại các bạn và với gì? Và với
cái hàm sum này. Các bạn ấn tab nhé. Sum
của bốn quý này nhé. Đấy, các bạn sẽ
đóng ngoặc đơn lại. Sau đó các bạn và
với gì ạ? Và cái mở ngoặc kép.
Đóng ngoặc đơn các bạn. Đóng ngoặc kép
lại. Đấy, các bạn enter.
Bây giờ các bạn sẽ kéo xuống, các bạn
tích đúp này. Đấy.
Bây giờ các bạn sẽ nháy chuột phải vào
đây nhé. Các bạn chọn gì ạ? Các bạn sẽ
chọn cái select data. Đấy. Thì các bạn
sẽ tích vào cái edit ở đây, tức là mình
sẽ edit cái tên dưới này này, là
horizontal đây này. Đấy. Các bạn sẽ tích
vào đây này, edit này. Và gì ạ? Các bạn
sẽ xóa cái này đi. Và các bạn sẽ lựa
chọn cái mới này.
Đấy, các bạn sẽ bấm ok. Các bạn sẽ bấm
ok. Thì như vậy là gì ạ? Cái phần tên ở
đây này, và nó sẽ hiện cái doanh thu
tổng ở đây là 57 này. Đấy, bạn gái Excel
2 tổng là 163. Đấy, các bạn thấy chưa?
Tổng này. Đấy, còn đây là tổng của các
cái quý riêng biệt.
Bây giờ giả sử mình muốn hiện cái 163
này gì ạ? Ở dưới này cơ. Thì các bạn sẽ
tích vào cái công thức này nhé. Đấy, các
bạn sẽ gì ạ? Các bạn sẽ tích đúp này. Để
mình sửa công thức nhé. Thì sau cái B31
này các bạn và với gì ạ? Các bạn có thể
và với cái hàm char(10). Char(10) chính
là cái
hàm để lấy cái ký tự enter đấy. Đấy, các
bạn enter đi. Đấy. Sau đó các bạn tích
đúp vào đây. Đấy, các bạn thấy chưa? Thì
như vậy, giá trị của tổng ở đây này,
đấy, nó sẽ nằm ở cái bên dưới này. Các
bạn thấy không? Dùng cái này rất là hay
luôn.
Thì như vậy mình đã hiểu được cái ông
gái Excel 1 này doanh thu là 57 đúng
không? Ông gái Excel 2 là doanh thu là
163. Còn nếu như mình muốn hiện doanh
thu của từng quý, ví dụ mình muốn hiện
cái quý 4 này chẳng hạn nhé, thì các bạn
sẽ tích vào cái quý 4 này, các bạn nháy
chuột phải. Các bạn chọn add data label.
Đấy, các bạn sẽ chọn vào đây.
Thì nó sẽ hiện giá trị tương ứng. Đấy,
chẳng hạn quý 1 nhé, các bạn tích vào
một cái quý 1 bất kỳ này. Các bạn nháy
chuột phải, các bạn add.
Các bạn trỏ vào cái tam giác này, các
bạn chọn gì ạ? Add data label. Đấy, các
bạn thấy không? Rất là hay luôn.
Ví dụ, cái cái đường gridline này mình
không cần thì các bạn có thể bỏ đi nhé.
Các bạn tích vào cái dấu cộng này, các
Các sẽ bỏ cái gridline này đi. Tại mình
thấy nó không được đẹp lắm.
Ok, cái chart title các bạn tích vào
đây.
Mình sẽ ghi là doanh thu.
Cả năm chẳng hạn thế nhá, đấy tùy các
bạn, các bạn muốn đặt tiêu đề là gì cũng
được. Đấy các bạn thấy không, rất là hay
luôn.
Đây là cái cách để mình sẽ biểu diễn là
gì ạ? Mình sẽ chồng các cái giá trị lên
nhau. Thì nhìn mình biết là gì ạ? Mình
vừa biết được là giá trị của từng cái
quý riêng và mình sẽ biết là tổng giá
trị nó sẽ tỷ lệ như thế nào. Đấy các bạn
thấy chưa? Thì dựa vào cái biểu đồ ấy
thì các bạn rất là đơn giản các bạn sẽ
biết được là gì ạ? Cái ông nào đang là
doanh thu lớn nhất, đấy, và nó sẽ có cái
trực quan hơn.
Ông gái sale 2 là doanh thu lớn nhất này
và ông gái sale 4 này là doanh thu nhỏ
nhất, đấy.
Và thì ok, như vậy là mình hướng dẫn
xong cho các bạn cái phần biểu đồ nhá.
Bây giờ mình sẽ xem cái câu hỏi của bài
tập về nhà.
Ok, câu hỏi của mình là gì ạ? Giả sử đây
là cái vùng dữ liệu của mình nhá. Bây
giờ yêu cầu của mình là gì ạ? Các bạn sẽ
hiện cho mình một cái biểu đồ doanh thu
tương tác như thế này.
Nhưng mà ở đây là gì ạ? Mình sẽ lựa chọn
được các cái quý. Ví dụ mình tích vào
đây mình chọn là quý 1 chẳng hạn thế
nhá. Thì ở đây nó lập tức nó sẽ hiểu là
gì ạ? Cái doanh thu, cái phần tiêu đề nó
phải là gì ạ? Doanh thu quý 1.
Cái biểu đồ ở đây nó chỉ là cho quý 1
thôi, đấy. Và gì ạ? Cái giá trị tổng nó
cũng thay đổi theo quý 1 thôi. Ví dụ gái
sale 1 này của quý 1 là 79 đúng không?
Gái sale 2 quý 1 là 70, đấy.
Các bạn thấy chưa? Ví dụ mình chọn cái
quý 2 chẳng hạn thế nhá. Thì như vậy đây
là cái biểu đồ doanh thu của quý 2. Nó
cũng thay đổi cái giá trị này và cái
tiêu đề nó cũng thay đổi là quý 2, đấy.
Đây là bài tập về nhà cho các bạn nhá.
Còn nếu như các bạn chọn all nhá, thì nó
sẽ biểu diễn là gì ạ? Tổng 4 quý ở đây.
Đấy các bạn thấy không, rất là đẹp luôn.
Tổng 4 quý của các các ông này. 287,
271, đấy.
Đây là cái biểu đồ tương tác nhá, các
bạn sẽ làm cho mình nhá.
Đây là sau khi mình làm rồi đấy, còn cái
file mà mình đính kèm cho các bạn để các
bạn luyện tập ấy, nó chỉ là cái vùng dữ
liệu này thôi nhá.
Ok, như vậy là mình đã kết thúc bài học
ngày hôm nay ở đây. Cảm ơn các bạn đã
theo dõi. Các bạn nhớ đăng ký kênh để
cập nhật video mới nhất của Gà, cũng như
chia sẻ để giúp mọi người cùng học Excel
nhé.
Xin chào và hẹn gặp lại.